[Music]
emmy's night it's gonna go down with you
girls right tonight is gonna be messy
last year was just like
and this year i i genuinely can't
believe i'm i'm in that pack again do
you feel any pressure to go back to back
with the winds
now i do
don't sweat it brett it can't be as
stressful as trying to keep his cameo in
thor love and thunder a secret opening
night of thor
i was in the audience that theater
was the loudest when you showed up on
the screen as hercules there's a lot of
people going who the is that
are you ready to go head-to-head against
chris hemsworth thor
yeah i mean he seems like a small guy
this
what was your reaction when you saw him
on the big screen as hercules it was
surreal
juno temple and all her friends are
truly having a moment miles teller her
co-star from the offer is still
celebrating top gun maverick and let's
not forget tick tock's obsession how
does this do it
i've heard from people about his
tick-tocking i love that man a lot
the cast of ted lasso has several months
until season three grabs but will it be
the end of the series
you've said that you are writing it as
the last season yeah when i said that
last time i got in big trouble so
if
this is the last scene and who knows
because anything could happen i had this
conversation with siddakis recently
and i was like dude what are you doing
and he was just like i don't know we'll
see we'll see